COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I respond to a question
from social media.
Will we answer only using emoji?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As you may have noticed,
most of the topics
we cover on this series
come from real-world issues
that customers and
developers are running into.
For example, Ed
Robinson here, asking
for some content on how to
profile Google Cloud Functions.
Ed, thanks for watching.
Here's what we've got for you.
Google Cloud Functions
is a serverless offering
on Google Cloud
that's still in beta,
at the time of this recording.
As such, there are still some
things that need ironing out.
But in the meantime,
here's some great ways
to get the info on the
performance of your functions.
In order to get a base
level understanding
of how your GCF
code is performing,
there's two things to look at.
First, you can view
your Cloud Functions
with their execution
times and execution counts
in the Cloud Platform Console.
From here, you can get aggregate
performance information
about how long it took
to deploy your function,
as well as how long it took
to respond to a request.
Now, there may be
situations where
you need to output some
content to your logs
in order to help debug
or mark specific events.
Calling the console.log
function in GCF
outputs a line to
the logs, which you
can view in the GCP Console.
At the time of this video,
full Stackdriver Tracing
is not integrated
with functions.
However, if you're looking
for more information,
there's a couple of things
you can do until then.
First is inline
function wrapping.
Since GCF logs can be
read via the gsutil API,
it's straightforward to wrap
core parts of your functions
with timer statements
and log those durations.
Later, you can walk
through that data
and check out how
each area is behaving
or import all of your
logging data into BigQuery
and do even deeper analysis.
Second is emulator timings.
Now, it turns out that
you can do quite a bit
to profile your code
locally through the emulator
before actually deploying it.
Now, technology
like the V8 Profiler
can help a ton
here, although you
might need to modify your
code to get it all working.
And of course, the
execution times
won't be exact since
your local machine may
have different performance
characteristics
than those in the cloud.
But you can still
get a good sense
of where the hotspots are.
If you'd like more
information about these tools
and some other ways to
profile your Cloud Functions,
check out the article linked
in the description below.
And in the coming weeks,
I'll be taking a look
at a few of the most common
GCF performance issues here
on Cloud Performance Atlas.
So stay tuned, because
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]